Have you ever knit a sweater, put all that
time and energy and money into knitting a
sweater.
Put it on and it just didn't fit.
Maybe it was too tight or too sloppy or
just something wasn't right about it.
Well, it's happened to all of us.
Let's spend some time today talking about.
Why that sweater didn't fit and what you
can do, so that doesn't happen to you
again.
Let's see.
You have a sweater that
fits that you just love.
Maybe you knit it or you bought it and
this thing just fits you like a glove and
it's your go to sweater.
Now your friend may come over and look
at you wearing that sweater and think to
herself, Oh, that's just way too tight.
She won't tell you that, but,
maybe the one she's wearing, you're
looking at her going, Hmm, that's really
sloppy and not so attractive.
Fit is very subjective.
It's really a personal thing.
So I can tell you to measure yourself and
make a sweater a certain size and you're
not going to be happy with it.
But here's the trick.
Find a sweater that you love, whether it's
in your closet or you find it in a store.
Go out shop and try some things on
and see what it is that you like.
Check the body, the fit.
Does it fit around the bust?
How about the shoulders or the shoulders?
Right?
Are the seams fallen off your shoulders?
How about the sleeve length?
Measure your sleeve from your
underarm down to your wrist.
How long do you like your sleeves?
This perfect sweater is going to be just
the right length, maybe just the right
height of the neck, opening
or depth of the neck opening.
Find that sweater, be comfortable
with it and take some measurements.
So tip number one is
don't measure your body.
Measure a sweater that you like,
which leads us to tip number two.
So how do you duplicate that sweater?
The key is choosing your pattern.
Now, no matter what patterns you use,
whether it's something out of a book or
something you get off the internet,
or maybe something that's generated in
software or even a Knit it Now pattern.
It's up to you to determine whether
that pattern is going to meet your
specifications, your dimensions
that you established.
So you need to, let's say we
take a pattern out of a book.
Take a look at the diagram,
the finished measurements.
Now let's not go and talk about
body measurements or anything else.
You want to know how many stitches are
around the widest part of that body,
right?
That sweater.
So if it has a diagram, check to see what
the widest width this and multiple ply
that by two to get your bust measurement.
Then compare that dimension
to your measurements.
So let's say I want my sweater
to be 40 inches around.
I will check the pattern to make sure that
the bust size that I choose to knit or the
sweater size that I choose
to knit is 40 inches around.
Probably 20 in the front
and 20 in the back.
If that pattern is 42 or 46
or 38 it's not going to fit.
I want it to be 40.
And if you can do the math and change that
pattern for yourself, Hey, good for you.
If not, don't use that pattern.
Find one that is your size.
Thanks where software comes in handy, and
that's really where Knit it Now patterns
come in handy, but we'll talk
more about that in a minute.
Alright, spoiler alert.
Tips number three, four, and
five, all have to do with gauge.
Now I'm not going to get on
my soapbox here about gauge.
I'm going to assume that you knit gage
swatches, and if you're not a believer, I
will remind you that if you're trying
to reproduce a size, if I'm trying to
reproduce that 40 inches, I need to know
how many stitches it's going to take to
make that 40 inches.
Accurately.
No guesswork.
If I'm trying to match a gauge to a
specific pattern, the designer came up
with, I don't know, 16
stitches to the inch.
My gauge must be 16 stitches to the inch.
If I'm off by just a little bit, think
about multiplying that around 40 inches,
and I'm going to get either a sweater that
I'm swimming in or one that I ashamed to
wear that shows all my lumps and bumps.
So if you've had sweaters that don't fit
and you are not religious about matching
gauge or establishing your gauge.
That's probably the number one
reason your sweater didn't fit.
I don't know about you,
but I hate to match gauge.
I think I've spent way too many hours over
the years trying to match my gauge to a
designer's gauge.
Let's say I knit something on my machine
and I use a specific yarn and I use
knitted at tension eight
and I get a specific gauge.
You could take that same Cone of yarn
on your machine at tension 8 and your
tension.
Your gauge might be different than mine
and you're going to have to adjust and
then another swatch.
Let's not even go there.
What I prefer to do is to knit a swatch
in my stitch pattern with whatever yarn I
want to knit, feel how it feels.
Dress it, see how it washes, see how it
hangs, see how it drapes, and then use my
gauge and create my own pattern.
Now you can do that using software.
You can use pencil and paper
and you can use knit it.
Now patterns with our
dynamic perfect fit patterns.
We're going to accomplish two things.
You're going to be able to use your gauge.
Measure your swatch, your gauge.
And you'll also be able to perfect fit the
pattern to match those dimensions that you
established.
So I will get that 40 inch finished
sweater without doing any math.
All I need to do is know my gauge.
The last tip, or the last step on my
soapbox is to measure, gauge accurately.
So many knitters struggle and their
sweaters don't fit because they made a
mistake in measuring.
So this is a skill that you must, must
learn, and here's a little exercise for
you.
You knit your swatch, you measure, you
dress your swatch, which means you wash
it, you steam it, whatever you're going to
do to the final garments, you dress that
swatch, and then you
take your measurements.
Then I want you to sit down with that same
yarn, same tension settings, everything
the same at that gauge, and I want you to
knit a rectangle that's, I don't know, six
by six inches by six inches.
Just choose a size.
If your rectangle comes out six
inches by six inches, you're golden.
You've measured your gauge.
Well, you've calculated the
gauge, well, you're all set.
If that is not six by six inches,
got to go back to the drawing board.
Something's wrong.
Now.
Isn't that a whole lot easier than
knitting the whole back of a sweater and
then realizing that maybe
your gauge is wrong?
So I challenge you to do this,
especially when you're new.
Until you get a feel for
knitting a proper swatch.
If you're having trouble with swatches,
please go Knititnow.com/Swatch.
It's filled with tutorials and tips and
tricks about swatching and establishing
gauge.
And I'll warn you, I do get up on my
soapbox on this subject in the classroom.
So for sweaters at fit, you
need to establish your size.
You need to choose the right pattern.
And swatch.
Swatch and swatch.
Thanks for watching and happy knitting.